how easily do you sleep on planes
because i i remember when i was like
with great difficulty so like for me
sleeping on the window seat is actually
less comfortable than sleeping on the
aisle seat as well because
because for some reason like you but
like mine
you know your nature is you know you can
lean on the on the wall part right
but the wall of the plane is i don't
know why it's just tilted at such an
angle where you can never get
a comfortable leaning on that wall it's
like
i don't know that's why you bring it up
i don't know what engineer designed it
to make planes especially on the
window seats the most uncomfortable
angle to lean your head by
yeah that is true and it is so weird
because
i have no trouble sleeping on cars cars
trains
any other kind of moving vehicle i sleep
like a [ __ ] baby
put me on a plane and i'm like insomnia
like insomnia speed running it's just
like well i i normally wear a hoodie and
a jacket no matter what the weather yeah
i'll use them as padding yeah because it
also gets [ __ ] cold
because i i like i need to be i need my
hair to be at least like a 45 degree
angle right
that's called privilege right no no no
no no no like like like
how does the how does sleepy in the
aisle make this solution better because
i can't
i can't tilt my neck enough that it's
like
it's almost like horizontal here's how i
i i kind of go like
the wall is here and the seat is here i
kind of nestled
into this corner yeah because it's kind
of like donkey
yeah yeah yeah i do that because because
like it's like for me like
i said my head needs to be like at least
a 45 degree angle so you know not not
you know
not my entire body but at least my head
you know so it feels at least like i'm
lying down even though i'm
i wake up i get [ __ ] neck cramps or
whatever like i just
just go business like at that point i am
honestly i have no problem just sleeping
like i just put my head down and sleep
on my arms on my lap
i can't do that i could do that i've
attempted to do that as well
and i'm just i'm too tall that sounds
like a short personal solution to me
this is why you're lower than six foot
you get you can just the world opens up
to you it's like a [ __ ] origami level
the 511 club over here
every time i go on a plane now i'm just
like damn man i wish i wish i was a bit
shorter i wish i was off the 511 club
how does it feel to be short oh my god
well that's the other benefit of being
in the ilc right is that you can stick
your legs out and actually stretch you
10 minutes and the woman comes over
she's like hey put your [ __ ] legs in
all the cart comes by and you like your
legs it's [ __ ] cool i'm like [ __ ]
right up against the seat though yeah
like it just slides past i don't know i
don't know man i don't like a jackie
chan film
but i also i don't know if i can do this
now because it's been
fine like two years since i've been on a
long flight yeah it's been a while
yeah yeah it's been like two years but i
used to i used to stay up all night
working and then my flight would be at
like what like maybe midday if i was
lucky yeah maybe 8 a.m if i was even
luckier yeah so i'd stay up all night
working
and then right before i got on the plane
i would just take one of those like
over-the-counter
really cheap weak sleeping pills the uk
ones yeah they're super
they're not like american like melatonin
no no
melatonin is the good [ __ ] yeah that's
like illegal in the uk or you need a
prescription to get melatonin oh really
yeah i think the one that you get from
the stores like similar to hay fever
medicine i think
uh like i swear to god that's your sugar
pills
it doesn't actually do much but it's
enough to like kind of get your head
going and you're like all right
i'm already sleep deprived i stayed up
all night working yeah and now i'm gonna
go to bed
because like when i would when uh what
was it two and a half years ago maybe
the latin the last con season i actually
did before pandemic
i went back and forth from america like
four times in one month
um to the uk yeah and the only way i
could do it was by sleeping i just like
i if if i need to sleep on a plane and i
don't have like melatonin or like
sleeping pills i've never taken
melatonin yeah i just go like
just give me like two gin and tonics
just just down fashion
alcohol doesn't work on me just to make
me sleep i don't know really like
to me i never drink alcohol on planes
because alcohol just
makes the fluids run through my body
faster so i just gotta pee more
so that that's just that just adds an
extra layer of stress for me because i'm
sorry i gotta pee more now i'm on this
plane i can not pee
i i can hold the pin i cannot pee that's
an out of context
i can hold the p for like the whole 12
hours
you're a mad man like i i unload before
i get on the plane
i fully unleash it and i drink minimal
water on the plane yeah well i'm pretty
sure
i'm pretty sure i unload as much like
possibly can i go to p like
five times before i get on the plane and
like i sit down immediately as i know
probably being five times we get in the
plane your bladder already sounds like
it's failed you before you even got to
the gate
i'm only playing like one i don't know
what it is though it's like it's like a
pavlovian effect where like the moment
you hear the doom
of like the seatbelt sign it's like a
[ __ ] i have to pee
every time i mean that's what i can hold
it and i can sleep so i'm like i tell
the people next to me like if they seem
nice
if if they don't seem nice i don't know
and say anything because you can just
tell us
tell them what well i'd be like don't if
the food comes don't work me out
i don't care about you don't wake me up
for anything so you're gonna say
don't worry uh don't worry if you have
to pee because uh i i'm i'm all for it
man
sometimes if you're in like if you're
asleep and they ask you do you want food
and they think that you're like actually
like conked out like completely
yeah they might think like oh my god
he's like he's fainted or something or
like
you know no i've done i've just if if
i'm if you don't wake up if you don't
wake up yeah if i'm on a plane
and i'm asleep while the food goes past
like i've never been woken up for food
oh my god
people wake me up so many times dude
that is i hate that and i'm like
do you know how hard i worked exactly
right
i waited two hours to get to sleep for
five [ __ ] minutes so you could wake
me up
this is why i also don't want to sit in
the [ __ ] in the aisle because the
moment i fall asleep
some person could be like excuse me can
i go to the toilet
you literally waited you waited until i
felt fall to sleep all right
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i hate you you're
a scum of the earth
i will watch the moment i see them about
to fall asleep i'm like i'm going to pee
if i'm in the
thing i want to give you yeah